now this movie are you gonna watch with
your kids I I'm planning on watching
this movie with my kids I'm planning on
watching it with family friends whoever
will watch with me at that moment we are
watching I'm like everybody come from
the neighborhood that's what I'm saying
like let's all gather around and watch
this movie it was it's funny they like
to tease me and and and my 11 year old
actually came to set and she was really
into watching I was like wow you're
really into watching this but I think
they they they love romantic movies the
girls John Hughes is their favorite and
my boys would probably just think it's
funny because Dad would probably think
it's funny but my girls loved to escape
into the world and they know that it's
all make-believe so I think they love to
they love to watch romance movies know
you and by the way it's it's like and by
the way like it's it's pretty innocent
you bring the camera do your kids wanna
be actors actresses would you want that
for them so my 11 year old wants to act
with all of her heart and soul and she
tells me about it every single day of
her life she loves it and then my
five-year-old actually just told me the
other day that he really wants to act
but he also wants to direct he wants to
direct scary movies cuz he's obsessed
with Halloween and obsessed with all
things scary so I would I would
encourage them to you know continue with
their education which I'm really trying
to encourage but that you know I I know
with especially Jagger it's like this is
her lifelong dream and so if she's
anything like I was which she is then I
don't really have a choice you know and
I turned out pretty good so I feel
pretty good about me so ok might there
be an opportunity and the new
Punkie I sure hope so I really hope that
she can be a part of it in some way well
tell me about it's so exciting it's so
exciting you know
well she's this incredible punky at
heart and and she's a single mom raising
some kids and she is rediscovering
herself she's just gone through a
divorce and really rediscovering who she
is and coming of age again and it's it's
it's so terrific I'm so excited what's
it like visiting her oh it's it's a
dream come true
truly I I always say that I didn't know
where punky ended and I began because we
were the same in so many ways and I
still believe that with all my heart and
Punky Brewster was such a part of my
heart and soul and such a beloved
character by me and so many others and
so to play a character that I love so
much and that you know connects to
people on such a deep level is truly a
dream come true so I everyday that I'm
at work right now Universal Studios I'm
just I'm so excited and I'm they're just
in total awe and enjoy well we just had
a big it's a very big deal cherry will
be back as my as my best friend so that
is the big new news yes punky and cherry
will still be besties oh I'm very
excited